le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
lorsque l'on se lance sur les sentiers
de l'île c'est un réconfort de trouver
un refuge ou faire escale
les gîtes public de montagne sont la
propriété du département pour améliorer
leurs capacités et leurs conditions
d'accueil
la collectivité a entamé un programme de
réhabilitation et de reconstruction à
mafate
le gîte dilate à bursa a été remise aux
normes et les randonneurs étaient au
rendez vous pendant ses vacances
[Musique]
temps
j'ai vu comment c'est beau la est-ce que
vous rendez compte des paysages pour
voilà c'est presque un pèlerinage pour
dimitri et aurélie illusion c'est
dionysien s'accorde quelques jours en
famille au coeur de mafate
on va il est il apte à bourse d'accor
c'est après horaire cette année les
randonneurs font escale pour la première
fois au gîte dit la bourse et au bout de
quelques heures de marche
le refuge tant attendu et dans toutes
les pensées ça se mérite on est content
d'arriver au gic le soir etc et de l'eau
chaude
voilà un bon livre qu'on commence bien
[Musique]
au gîte de lille est en fin d'après midi
les premiers randonneurs font leur
arrivée au bout de champ droit
christophe est le gérant du site depuis
dix ans le gîte deal est à bourg c'est
le tout premier gîte de mafate une
institution récemment rénové et remise
aux normes
ici avant c'était l'apprentissage
changer des cloisons tout ou
transformées derrière aussi oui ici
avant il y avait dortoir sanitaires ont
maintenant fait partie ça va manger à
l'extérieur un accès pour les personnes
à mobilité réduite a été ajouté il mène
à une chambre adaptés pendant les
rénovations pour accessible le gîte deal
est à bourse est l'un des onze sites
publics de montagne ces établissements
sont la propriété du département et sont
gérés par l'eau nf depuis 2015 un
programme de réhabilitation et de
reconstruction est en cours
les grands politiques consiste
effectivement à permettre une qualité
touristique de pointe avec des
structures d'accueil approprié qui sont
en résonance avec les sites
départementaux domaniaux à destination
donc les touristes des randonneurs des
marcheurs
nous avons intégré dans notre plan donc
de valorisation une reconstruction
totale des gîte du piton des neiges
les gîtes donc du piton de la fournaise
gîte de bélouve avec aussi un plan de
restructuration lourds qui permettra et
bien aux usagers de pouvoir allier le
confort aux plaisirs des sites
départementaux
jacques monsieur thomas après quatre
heures de marche la famille letourneur
découvre son refuge pour la nuit
[Musique]
bonjour dimitri ont chanté aurait mis en
chasse et donc on est content de
découvrir la table on s'est dit voyons
là on l'a bien mérité on va pouvoir
avoir un peu de confort une motion et
l'apéritif la merci bien là tout allait
se reposer un peu avant de l'attaquer
dans la chambre une bonne surprise
attend les visiteurs
on est bien la fille nicole ses proches
terreur des individuels et des toilettes
individuelles dans mafate
pendant que les randonneurs profite de
ce confort la question de se relâcher
pour christophe le jt complet et l'heure
du repas approche depuis depuis le matin
jusqu'au soir pape aurait pu le préparer
[Musique]
c'est dans la salle à manger rénové que
la journée s'achève autour d'un bon cari
a bien un très bon accueil
superbe
[Musique]
le département est propriétaire de digit
public ils sont gérés par le nf exploité
par l'association des gestionnaires des
gîtes de montagne le département a déjà
investi plus de 3 millions d'euros dans
la réhabilitation de cinq gîtes un
programme de reconstruction est en cours
pour les gîte du piton de la fournaise
du piton des neiges et de bélouve pour
plus de renseignements ou pour des
réservations vous pouvez vous rapprocher
de la centrale de réservation régional
au 02 62 90 78 78 ou consulter le site
[Musique]
www.exxonmobil.com